Katrina: 那烤肉调料可以上上烤架了是吗
Katrina: Can we put the seasoning on the grill now?
Shure: 来吧来吧
Shure: Come on, come on.
Shure: 出出来往出整吧
Shure: Get it out and set it up.
Shure: 可以的可以的
Shure: Yes, it works.
Alice:放了啊
Alice: I'll put it in.
Shure: 这温度够
Shure: This temperature is enough.
Alice:差不多了
Alice: Almost done.
Shure: 无敌
Shure: Invincible.
Shure: 真无敌
Shure: Truly invincible.
Jake:耶
Jake: Yay.
Jake:大成功
Jake: Big success.
Alice:左右怎么是不通风的
Alice: Why is it not ventilated on both sides?
Alice:就这吧
Alice: Let's go with this.
Alice:恩，不对
Alice:是着了的
Alice: This one's lit.
Shure: 有没有没着的
Shure: Is there one that's not lit?
Alice:有有个完全没着的
Alice: Yes, there's one that's completely unlit.
Shure: 哪个
Shure: Which one?
Alice:走边
Shure: 最左边那个是吗OK
Shure: The one on the far left? OK.
Shure: 先把它也拿出去
Shure: Let's take it out first.
Shure: 然后一会拿着勺
Shure: Then get a spoon.
Shure: 哎你现在这个应该是着了的
Shure: Hey, this one should be lit now.
Shure: 哎这个着了这个着了来
Shure: Hey, this one's lit, this one's lit, come on.
Shure: 你还是先把他这么侧着吧
Shure: You should tilt it this way first.
Shure: 草早这样早他妈好
Shure: Damn, it would've been better this way earlier.
Alice:你把那一面放上面
Alice: Put that side on top.
Shure: 对放上面
Shure: Yeah, put it on top.
Alice:最左边那个没
Alice: The one on the far left isn't...
Alice:没熟没没
Alice: It's not done, no, no.
Shure: 这个
Shure: This one.
Alice:这两边好像都是
Alice: These two sides seem...
Alice:这个有一点点
Alice: This one is a little bit.
Shure: 这也够呛
Shure: This one's still not quite right.
Katrina: 就拿这个吧
Katrina: Let's just use this one.
Shure: 有点情调啊
Shure: It's got a bit of ambiance.
Katrina: 这可以直接喝
Katrina: You can drink this directly.
Katrina: 需要兑东西吗
Katrina: Do we need to mix it with anything?
Shure: 就是今天买那个吗
Shure: Is this the one we bought today?
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yes.
Shure: 对直接喝就行
Shure: Yeah, you can drink it directly.
Shure: 然后你觉得不行你再兑东西
Shure: If you don't like it, you can mix it with something.
Alice:上面有几根
Alice: How many are on top?
Shure: 上面还有俩
Shure: There are still two on top.
Alice:这个也不行
Alice: This one doesn't work either.
Alice:这个也得点点吧
Alice: This one needs to be lit too.
Shure: 行
Shure: Okay.
Alice:一点没熟
Alice: It's not cooked at all.
Shure: 他一次只能点着一根
Shure: He can only light one at a time.
Shure: 他只有那边那根能点着
Shure: Only that one over there can be lit.
Shure: 因为风是往那边吹所以点不着
Shure: Because the wind is blowing that way, it won't light.
Alice:小火慢炖得了
Shure: 对好放这吧
Shure: Yeah, let's put it here.
Shure: OK然后先放上把这羊排可以弄上
Shure: OK, let's put this lamb chop on.
Shure: 哎放这吧放这吧
Shure: Hey, put it here.
Alice:但是你待会不好拿下来呀
Alice: But it will be hard to take it off later.
Alice:这倒热倍快
Shure: 是吗
Shure: Really?
Shure: 拿拿夹子都是
Shure: Use the tongs to take it off.
Shure: 对那个放上放上吧
Shure: Yeah, put it on.
Alice:可以了
Alice: It's fine.
Shure: 好不行从这往里夹嘛
Shure: Okay, if not, grab it from here.
Alice:这就是放碳的
Shure: 这其实应该是烤串用的
Shure: This should be for grilling skewers.
Alice:确实
Shure: 很好熟吧应该
Shure: It should cook well.
Alice:一上来就放这么大块的
Alice: You put such a big piece on right away.
Alice:可以多放点
Alice: You can put more on.
Shure: 旁边就慢慢围着是吧
Shure: Just circle it slowly on the side, right?
Jake:嗯确实不太好端
Jake: Yeah, it's really hard to handle.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Alice:有这么厚
Alice: It's this thick.
Alice:有这么薄呢
Alice: It's this thin too.
Shure: 他也整不着整半天
Shure: He can't get it done even after a long time.
Shure: 刚整着一半吧
Shure: Just half done, I guess.
Shure: 直接放上面了
Shure: Just put it on top directly.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm
Shure: 卧槽你牛逼
Shure: Wow, you're awesome
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah
Shure: 你怎么没把他最红的那边冲上
Shure: Why didn't you wash the reddest part?
Alice:没看见
Alice: Didn't see it
Alice:来段来段快板
Alice: Let's have a quick rap
Shure: 同仁堂开的
Shure: From Tongrentang
Shure: 本是老药铺
Shure: It's an old pharmacy
Shure: 先生好比甩手自在王
Shure: The master is like a carefree king
Shure: 药王爷就在当中
Shure: The Medicine King is in the middle
Shure: 坐实得名医列两旁
Shure: Famous doctors are seated on both sides
Alice:好来袋炸莓啊
Alice: Good, let's have some fried berries
Shure: 这没个灯真不行
Shure: It's really hard without a light
Shure: 我看不着肉的色你知道吗
Shure: I can't see the color of the meat, you know?
Alice:嗯让杨老板尝一下
Alice: Hmm, let Jake taste it
Shure: 好家伙先拿
Shure: Sure, let him try first
Shure: 老板识毒是吧
Shure: The boss can tell, right?
Shure: 咱们这员工真牛逼
Shure: Our staff is really awesome
Alice:感觉这个气都不足了哎哟
Alice: Feels like there's not enough air
Shure: 换一个那就咱把这个熄了
Shure: 着了吗他俩最后还没着呢
Shure: Did they light it up? Not yet?
Alice:一点点点
Alice: Just a little bit
Alice:来个猛的
Alice: Go for a strong one
Alice:一点点
Alice: A little bit
Alice:筷子呢
Alice: Where are the chopsticks?
Shure: 筷子在他手
Shure: The chopsticks are in his hand
Alice:我去翻看看
Alice: I'll go check it out
Shure: 要你干什么用
Shure: What are you even for?
Katrina: 生气了
Katrina: Getting mad
Shure: 等吃吧你就
Shure: Just wait to eat
Katrina: 就是镊子不好用吗
Katrina: Why not use tweezers?
Alice:这镊子夹碳的脏的
Alice: These tweezers are for charcoal, they're dirty
Alice:感觉一开始烤肥的会好一点
Alice: I think grilling the fatty parts first would be better
Alice:因为那个油会滴下去
Alice: Because the oil will drip down
Shure: 油低下去是吧
Shure: The oil drips down, right?
Alice:有希望能熟反正
Alice: Hopefully it will cook, anyway
Shure: 咱就吃3分熟今天
Shure: We'll eat it medium-rare today
Shure: 卧槽这其实很热的
Shure: Wow, this is actually very hot
Shure: 这俩应该是感觉差不多
Shure: These two should be almost done
Shure: 那个大的
Shure: That big one.
Alice:搁着呢筷子呢
Alice: Where are the chopsticks?
Shure: 行看着吧
Shure: Alright, just watch it.
Shure: 感觉差不多
Shure: Seems about right.
Shure: 就翻一翻
Shure: Just flip it over.
Shure: 一分钟翻一次就行
Shure: Flip it every minute, that'll do.
Katrina: 只有4个
Katrina: Only four of them.
Katrina: 他们哦
Katrina: Oh, they...
Katrina: 还是他没人
Katrina: Or no one for him.
Katrina: 有一种早期那种围炉取暖的感觉
Katrina: It feels like the old days when we used to warm ourselves by the stove.
Shure: 再烧一会
Shure: Let it burn a bit longer.
Shure: 也可以
Shure: That works too.
Katrina: 你可以放桌上呢
Katrina: You can put it on the table.
Katrina: 啊那放里面吧
Katrina: Ah, let's put it inside then.
Katrina: 现在感觉还没熟呢
Katrina: It doesn't seem fully cooked yet.
Shure: 离熟还有点距离
Shure: Still a bit to go before it's done.
Shure: 放下放下
Shure: Put it down, put it down.
Shure: 再烧一会
Shure: Let it burn a bit longer.
Shure: 拿三个吧
Shure: Take three.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 可以有那味儿
Shure: It has that flavor.
Shure: 我真感觉得弄一个
Shure: I really think we should get one.
Alice:内打光灯是不是也得通电
Alice: Does that fill light need to be plugged in too?
Shure: 对补光
Shure: Yes, for extra light.
Shure: 咱们队都得供电
Shure: Our team needs to provide power for everything.
Shure: 他没有能用充电宝供电的东西
Shure: He doesn't have anything that can run on a power bank.
Alice:好了起来了
Alice: Alright, it's up and running.
Alice:滴油了
Alice:往前一推就行了
Alice: Just push it forward, and that's it.
Shure: 牛太牛了
Shure: That's impressive.
Shure: 炭烧透了
Shure: The charcoal is thoroughly burned.
Alice:哎你这是碳
Alice: Hey, is this charcoal?
Shure: 没事还没碰到呢
Shure: It's okay, it hasn't touched yet.
Shure: 碰到了你也就当刚刚没有看到好吧
Shure: Even if it did, just pretend you didn't see it, alright?
Alice:好的那个给老板
Alice: Okay, give it to the boss.
Shure: 是的说犒劳老板
Shure: Yes, let's reward the boss.
Alice:好老板的死活不是死活
Alice: The boss's life is not just his life.
Shure: 老板的命不能让他是命
Shure: The boss's life can't be treated like just a life.
Alice:牛逼
Alice: Awesome.
Shure: 也有可能是这个碳太低了
Shure: Maybe the charcoal is too low.
Alice:这边还可以先放点这
Alice: Over here, we can put some of this first.
Alice:这啥也是有温度的
Alice: This thing is warm too.
Shure: 是吗
Shure: Really?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yep.
Alice:可以把串先放到这
Alice: You can put the skewers here first.
Alice:烘着
Alice: Let them dry.
Alice:是的
Alice:好我来吧
Alice:你别打灯我看看
Alice: Don't turn on the light, let me see.
Alice:着了
Alice: It's on fire.
Alice:还有吗
Alice: Any more?
Shure: 还有
Shure: Yes, there is.
Alice:在这熄火一会中毒了
Alice: If we don't turn off the heat, we'll get poisoned.
Alice:烤烤吧
Alice:这羊肉不刷油行吗
Alice: Is it okay not to brush oil on this lamb?
Alice:感觉不太行啊
Alice: Doesn't seem right.
Shure: 行吧这本身带油的
Shure: It's fine, it's naturally fatty.
Alice:我们今天吃原味的
Alice: We're having the original flavor today.
Alice:你要不把那羊肉串拿过来点
Alice: Can you bring those lamb skewers over?
Shure: 让我在那边再推他吗
Shure: Should I push him over there again?
Alice:希腊掌管烧烤的神
Alice: The Greek god of BBQ.
Shure: OK最后一块
Shure: Okay, the last piece.
Shure: 真够烤的这羊排
Shure: This lamb chop is really well roasted.
Shure: 薄的这个我感觉可以拿出来
Shure: This thin one, I think it's ready.
Shure: 就这一个是没问题的
Shure: Just this one is good to go.
Alice:这还有个
Alice: There's another one here.
Shure: 小心那个别碰着那铁子
Shure: Be careful not to touch the metal.
Jake:就整个手嘛
Jake: Just use your whole hand.
Alice:你就往上随便一摆吧翻一下就行
Alice: Just place it on top and flip it casually.
Katrina: 英雄终于有用武之地了
Katrina: The hero finally has a place to shine.
Tasha: 烧烤组
Tasha: BBQ team.
Shure: 火越来越旺了
Shure: The fire is getting stronger.
Shure: 越来越唧唧冒油了
Shure: More and more oil is dripping.
Shure: 那牛排
Shure: That steak...
Alice:这是羊排
Alice: This is lamb chop.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Oh.
Shure: 我去厨房先给大家煎俩牛排吃
Shure: I'll go to the kitchen and fry a couple of steaks for everyone.
Shure: 卧槽倍儿香
Shure: Damn, it smells so good.
Alice:我们家就老在阳台上烤肉吃
Alice: We always barbecue on the balcony at home.
Alice:也得熟了
Alice: It should be done.
Jake:但是固定手机确实不太合适
Jake: But fixing the phone like this isn't really convenient.
Alice:好一个大馋丫头
Alice:你吃你吃
Alice: Eat, eat.
Alice:你吃一下熟不熟
Alice: Try it and see if it's cooked.
Alice:熟吗那三二那个值吗
Alice: Is it cooked? What about that 32?
Shure: 这样还有这个
Shure: Like this, and then this.
Shure: 这方绝逼可以治
Shure: This way can definitely work.
Alice:这俩应该可以了
Alice: These two should be fine.
Shure: 这个这也可以
Shure: This one can work too.
Lucia: 因为咱们的那个啥插板没那么长
Lucia: Because our plug board isn’t that long.
Jake:外边没有电哈
Jake: There's no power outside, huh?
Alice:老板要不要尝一个
Alice: Boss, do you want to try one?
Jake:啊好了
Jake: Ah, okay.
Shure: 好了好了
Shure: Alright, alright.
Shure: 快快快叫出来叫出来快快快
Shure: Quick, quick, quick, call them out.
Alice:哎呦呦我去
Alice: Oh my gosh.
Jake:我去怎么吃
Jake: How do we eat this?
Alice:不行不行
Alice: No, no.
Jake:这个真
Jake: This is really...
Alice:干嘛
Alice: What?
Jake:这边真的没电吗
Jake: Is there really no power here?
Shure: 我没没吐没吐
Shure: I didn't, I didn't vomit.
Shure: 没吐我就
Shure: I didn't vomit, I just...
Alice:你你把你把芝麻给我呗
Alice: You, you give me the sesame seeds.
Shure: 撒点芝麻是吗
Shure: Sprinkle some sesame seeds, right?
Alice:芝麻跟辣椒面自己撒吧
Alice: Sprinkle the sesame seeds and chili powder yourself.
Shure: 这个很咸
Shure: This is very salty.
Alice:这个已经很咸了
Alice: This is already very salty.
Alice:你不管了
Alice: You don't care.
Jake:哎这不是插座吗
Jake: Hey, isn't this a socket?
Jake:我靠
Jake: Oh my god.
Jake:这不是插座吗卧槽
Jake: Isn't this a socket? Damn.
Shure: 我操快快快
Shure: Damn, quick, quick.
Shure: 拿出来一个
Shure: Take one out.
Shure: 我快快瞎了都
Shure: I'm going blind.
Alice:这个烤会吧再
Alice: Let's grill this a bit more.
Shure: 没问题应该
Shure: Should be fine.
Alice:这个不行的
Alice: This one won't do.
Shure: 这可以这真真可以
Shure: This one can definitely work.
Shure: 你看一点血没有
Shure: Look, there's no blood at all.
Alice:比较嫩
Alice: It's quite tender.
Shure: 我爱吃嫩的
Shure: I love it tender.
Alice:但是我们这一会加生一会加熟的好吗
Alice: But we keep adding raw and then cooked, okay?
Alice:唉算了
Alice: Sigh, never mind.
Alice:就这样吧
Shure: 他俩
Shure: 他最开始最后一下和最最开始一下
Shure: 是不是都是我们加的
Shure: 所以他一直在这个
Alice:随便无所谓
Alice:快来个灯吧，我要瞎了家人
Shure: 我操有灯了有灯了
Jake:哎还得是得彩排一次
Shure: 对所有的都得彩排
Shure: 不然话到时候啥都
Jake:对你们表演一般怎么个彩排法
Shure: 挑两手试一下
Shure: 哎别别扣上他那挺埋汰的
Alice:啊
Shure: 那盖是脏的
Shure: 行
Shure: 加点大自然的味道
Alice:再能俩近点吗
Shure: 可以
Shure: 应该撩不着
Shure: You probably won't get her.
Shure: 太牛逼了
Shure: That's awesome!
Lucia: 嗯纸了呀在这
Lucia: Hmm, the paper is here.
Shure: 这头让他抬抬
Shure: Make him lift his head.
Jake:我靠确实牛逼
Jake: Wow, this is really awesome.
Jake:就拿石头买卖
Jake: Just trading stones.
Jake:确实牛逼
Jake: Truly awesome.
Jake:这光一打确实牛逼的多
Jake: The lighting really makes it more awesome.
Alice:好手机扔一边吧
Alice: Okay, put the phone aside.
Jake:来师傅
Jake: Come on, master.
Alice:干嘛
Alice: What's up?
Jake:两位师傅来
Jake: Both masters, come here.
Shure: 一人一人摆拍一下先
Shure: Let's take turns posing for a photo first.
Alice:好
Alice: Alright.
Jake:摆拍摆拍
Jake: Pose, pose.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake:挺厉害
Jake: Pretty impressive.
Alice:咋了
Alice: What's up?
Shure: 来吃饭好了
Shure: Let's eat now.
Jake:来 2号师傅
Jake: Come on, Master Number 2.
Jake:你给他摆一摆
Jake: You set it up for him.
Shure: 快来吃饭喽
Shure: Come on, let's eat.
Alice:就熟了两块水咋吃
Alice: How do we eat with just two pieces cooked?
Shure: 吃饭吃饭
Shure: Let's eat, let's eat.
Shure: 凉了真凉了
Shure: It's really getting cold.
Jake:哈哈哈刚烤上
Jake: Haha, it just got grilled.
Shure: 吃饭吃饭
Shure: Let's eat, let's eat.
Katrina: 毕竟你是自己做的
Katrina: After all, you made it yourself.
Jake:刚烤上一分钟就凉了
Jake: It got cold after just one minute on the grill.
Shure: 快快快不然话凉了凉了真凉了
Shure: Hurry, hurry, otherwise it will get cold, really cold.
Jake:完了完了
Jake: It's over, it's over.
Alice:也行还行
Alice: It's okay, still alright.
Shure: 嗯呐不会了今天
Shure: Hmm, won't happen today.
Alice:哎
Shure: 人都到齐
Shure: Everyone's here.
Shure: 开香槟
Shure: Open the champagne.
Shure: 先吃吧真的太要凉了
Shure: Let's eat first, it's really going to get cold.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Jake:哎来拿一串
Jake: Hey, come grab a skewer.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Shure: 就是再拿一个小刀什么的吧
Shure: Just grab another small knife or something.
Shure: 因为这个牌好像不是能一人一个的
Shure: Because this card can't be shared by everyone.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Shure: 正好那个
Shure: Exactly that.
Jake:哦哦这么回事
Jake: Oh, I see.
Jake:就总共三个是吧
Jake: There are only three, right?
Shure: 一二现在这顶上几个
Shure: One, two, and how many on top now?
Jake:是是吗
Jake: Is that so?
Jake:这这这有你啊
Jake: This, this, this includes you?
Lucia: 这这这个是第三个吗
Lucia: Is this the third one?
Jake:这啥呀
Jake: What is this?
Jake:你你你看看吧我咱整不明白这啥
Jake: Look, I don't understand what this is.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia: 我这外面确实挺冷的
Lucia: It's really cold outside.
Shure: 卧槽这可以
Shure: Whoa, this is good.
Lucia: 烤串得赶快吃
Lucia: Hurry up and eat the kebabs.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mm.
Alice:这俩差不多了拿盘把
Alice: These two are almost done, bring a plate.
Lucia: 大家这么谦让我就先吃了
Lucia: Since everyone is being so polite, I'll eat first.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 我去哈哈哈
Lucia: I'll go, haha.
Shure: 都可以了
Shure: All done.
Alice:这两样可以
Alice: These two are fine.
Jake:好咱咱咱确实要整点刀
Jake: Okay, we definitely need some knives.
Alice:给我留一个肥一点的谢谢
Alice: Save me a fatty one, please.
Katrina: 然后可以
Katrina: Then it's okay.
Shure: 好
Shure: Alright.
Jake:除了菜刀的一些刀
Jake: Except for the kitchen knives.
Shure: 那你把它一直放
Shure: Just keep it there.
Shure: 放在那边围着
Shure: Put it over there.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Alice:这个不能是总是我的吧
Alice: This can't always be mine, right?
Alice:这不是把刀切了吗
Alice: Haven't we already cut this?
Alice:这个还没太熟呢
Alice: This isn't fully cooked yet.
Alice:搁这吧再烤会
Alice: Leave it here to roast a bit more.
Shure: 然后进去拿刀
Shure: Then go get the knife.
Shure: 拿个小刀
Shure: Get a small knife.
Katrina: 就只有两个
Katrina: There are only two.
Shure: 小刀对能切羊排的餐刀
Shure: A small knife, yes, one that can cut lamb chops.
Shure: 最好是餐刀
Shure: A table knife would be best.
Shure: 不要不行不行
Shure: No, no, no.
Alice:那啥能搁上来吧
Alice: Can we put this on?
Alice:把那鸡翅搁来吧
Alice: Bring those chicken wings over here.
Alice:那鸡翅太慢了
Alice: Those chicken wings are too slow.
Alice:慢慢弄吧
Alice: Take your time.
Shure: 先烤联筷子给大家喂上行吧
Shure: Let's start roasting and get some chopsticks to feed everyone.
Jake:没有小刀
Jake: No small knives.
Alice:菜刀
Alice: Kitchen knife.
Shure: 我操整吧那就
Shure: Damn, let's just do it then.
Jake:没有小刀
Jake: No small knives.
Jake:你你给我个镜头
Jake: Give me the camera.
Shure: 啊哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:我来切了
Jake: I'll cut it.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Okay.
Alice:这都会掉不回
Alice: This will all fall out.
Shure: 这真应该弄个帘子
Shure: We really need to get a curtain.
Shure: 我草真会掉
Shure: Damn, it will really fall.
Shure: 这小子这可咋整我草啊
Shure: What should we do with this guy, damn.
Lucia: 34
Lucia: 56
Shure: 不行就这个吧
Shure: If not, then let's go with this.
Shure: 这个涮涮凑合用一下
Shure: We can make do with this.
Lucia: 好就这样
Lucia: Alright, let's do it this way.
Alice:可以刷刷
Alice: We can use it.
Jake:还有别的菜刀吗
Jake: Do we have other kitchen knives?
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Oh no.
Shure: 快快快帮他下
Shure: Quick, help him out.
Shure: 快帮他下
Jake:还有别的菜刀吗
Jake: Do we have other kitchen knives?
Jake:就一个菜刀吗
Jake: Only one kitchen knife?
Alice:看来拿个啥东西
Alice: Looks like we need to get something.
Lucia: 压一下什么
Lucia: Press something down.
Lucia: 这给他往里塞点
Lucia: Put some of this inside for him.
Alice:往这边转一点点
Alice: Turn it a bit this way.
Alice:谢谢
Alice: Thanks.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice:姐的技术你放心姐是天台战神
Alice: Don't worry about my skills, I'm the rooftop goddess.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 我给姐升高一点好吧
Shure: I'll raise it a bit higher for you, alright?
Shure: OK了
Shure: It's all good now.
Alice:这个再烤一下下
Alice: Let's grill this a bit more.
Alice:没事先这样放着
Alice: It's fine, leave it like this for now.
Shure: 这些应该都熟了吧
Shure: These should all be cooked, right?
Shure: 打个光看一眼
Shure: Shine a light to check.
Shure: 还没有
Shure: Not yet.
Alice:再加一点
Shure: 呢这个应该差不多了吧
Shure: This one should be almost done.
Shure: 可以
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 真来吃吧
Shure: Let's really eat now.
Shure: 再不吃真凉了
Shure: If we don't eat now, it'll get cold.
Shure: 没问题来吧来吧
Shure: No problem, come on, come on.
Alice:我要肥一点
Alice: I want a fattier piece.
Alice:谢谢
Alice: Thanks.
Alice:今晚我来烤吧
Alice: I'll do the grilling tonight.
Shure: 我来吧
Shure: I'll do it.
Katrina: 哇
Katrina: Wow.
Alice:哇
Alice: Wow.
Shure: 不不不呸
Shure: No, no, no, pfft.
Lucia: 都什么
Shure: 雨轩雨轩雨轩
Shure: Yuxuan, Yuxuan, Yuxuan.
Jake:不是客观规律吗
Jake: Isn't this an objective law?
Shure: 偷偷吃不等他们了
Shure: Let's eat secretly without waiting for them.
Shure: 叫我半天不来吃
Shure: They called me but didn't come to eat.
Alice:快来吃吧
Alice: Come eat quickly.
Alice:真的熟了
Alice: It's really cooked.
Shure: 我靠你直接一块全啃了是吧
Shure: Oh wow, you just gnawed the whole piece, huh?
Alice:就可以拿下来了
Alice: You can take it down now.
Katrina: 嗯好好吃
Katrina: Mmm, it's delicious.
Alice:怎么样
Alice: How is it?
Katrina: 忒香了
Katrina: It's so fragrant.
Shure: 这个可以拿下来是吗
Shure: Can we take this down?
Alice:这是生的
Alice: This is raw.
Shure: 这是生的那个
Shure: This one is raw.
Alice:那个那个那个
Alice: That, that, that one.
Shure: 这几个
Shure: These few.
Alice:不是这俩都是生的
Alice: No, both of these are raw.
Alice:他们怎么不过来呢
Alice: Why aren't they coming over?
Shure: 谁知道呢
Shure: Who knows?
Alice:能给主厨来一块吗有点饿
Alice: Can we give the chef a piece? I'm a bit hungry.
Shure: 给主厨啃一口去
Shure: Let the chef take a bite.
Alice:去拿一个
Alice: Go get one.
Alice:我想吃带骨头的
Alice: I want to eat one with a bone.
Alice:对
Alice: Right.
Alice:谢谢
Alice: Thank you.
Shure: 这样是不是会更好一些
Shure: Wouldn't this be better?
Alice:确实
Alice: Indeed.
Alice:有水吗
Alice: Is there water?
Katrina: 可以出去吧
Katrina: Can we go out?
Alice:就就给我拿一碗水就行
Alice: Just bring me a bowl of water.
Alice:自来水就行
Alice: Tap water is fine.
Katrina: 一人一个腿呀
Katrina: One leg for each person.
Jake:还有吗还有吗还有吗还有吗
Jake: More? More? More? More?
Lucia: 好的这个你看他就是会那个啥
Lucia: Alright, you see, he's good at this.
Lucia: 就他这边安进去之后这边就不太好安
Lucia: Once he fixes this side, the other side is hard to fix.
Shure: 都可以都可以吃吧
Shure: Can we all eat now?
Shure: 本来反正就没有
Shure: There was nothing anyway.
Alice:我感觉我们可能吃不完
Alice: I feel like we might not finish it.
Alice:这碳就烧没了
Alice: The charcoal will burn out.
Shure: 他说能烧5-6个小时啊
Shure: He said it could burn for 5-6 hours.
Alice:什么哦放这就行了
Alice: Oh, just put it here.
Shure: 他绝对无敌
Shure: He's absolutely unbeatable.
Jake:干羊排
Jake: Dry lamb chops.
Shure: 那羊排谁没吃着
Shure: Who didn't get any lamb chops?
Shure: 然后把那一块都吃了吧
Shure: Let's eat all of that piece then.
Jake:我再拿个灯下来吧
Jake: I'll grab another light.
Jake:我这边也打掉
Jake: I'll turn this one off.
Lucia: 嗯好
Lucia: Hmm, okay.
Alice:这个刀呢
Alice: Where's the knife?
Jake:哎为啥呀
Jake: Hey, why?
Alice:没有刀吗
Alice: No knife?
Alice:哎呀来一块吧
Alice: Oh well, let's just have a piece.
Katrina: 我来烤吧
Katrina: I'll do the grilling.
Katrina: 你开吗给你录一下
Katrina: Are you starting? I'll record it for you.
Lucia: 那我啃这个骨头了
Lucia: Then I'll gnaw on this bone.
Katrina: 跟你这样拍
Katrina: I'll film you like this.
Katrina: 拍高一点
Katrina: Film a bit higher.
Jake:给你打个灯
Jake: I'll light it up for you.
Jake:慢点慢点慢点
Jake: Slow down, slow down, slow down.
Jake:给你打灯给你打灯
Jake: I'll light it up for you.
Katrina: 哈哈哈笑死我了
Katrina: Hahaha, you're killing me with laughter.
Katrina: 你是某个那种晚会的
Katrina: Are you from one of those evening shows?
Jake:瓶下留人
Jake: Leave some for later.
Alice:有点干巴
Alice: It's a bit dry.
Alice:有没有那种油比较多的肉啊
Alice: Is there any meat that's a bit fattier?
Alice:干嘛呢
Alice: What are you doing?
Alice:bong
Alice: Bong.
Lucia: 这串看起来有都差不多的样子
Lucia: This skewer looks about the same.
Alice:买个串串吧
Alice: Buy a skewer.
Alice:没声啊
Alice: No sound?
Jake:跟火一样打不着
Jake: Can't light it like fire.
Shure: 不知道啊
Shure: I don't know.
Shure: 没开过 39块钱的呀
Shure: Never opened a 39 yuan one.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 他妈啤酒平时喝一杯还他妈40呢
Shure: Damn, a beer usually costs 40 bucks.
Shure: 好可以了
Shure: Alright, good to go.
Shure: 这回准备
Shure: Get ready.
Shure: 321
Shure: 3, 2, 1.
Shure: 虽然很不优雅
Shure: Though it's not very elegant,
Jake:但是很成功
Jake: But it's successful.
Katrina: 去换他一下吧
Katrina: Go and flip it.
Katrina: 感觉他一直靠我来考吧
Katrina: Feels like he's been relying on me to check it.
Katrina: 就是翻一下就行是吧
Katrina: Just flip it over, right?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Katrina: 拿手翻还是拿夹子翻
Katrina: Should I use my hands or tongs to flip it?
Alice:手不会烫的
Alice: Your hands won't get burned.
Katrina: 你去吃点吧
Katrina: You should go eat something.
Alice:油比较多一点的
Alice: There's quite a bit of oil.
Shure: 这个其实那肉就挺多的
Shure: Actually, there's a lot of meat here.
Shure: 拿筷子翻哈哈哈
Shure: Flip it with chopsticks, haha.
Shure: 是感觉这肉油不够吗
Shure: Does it feel like the meat doesn't have enough oil?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Shure: 嗯要不就再
Shure: Hmm, maybe we should...
Shure: 加点油
Shure: Add more oil.
Shure: 反正那是腌的
Shure: It's marinated anyway.
Katrina: 直接直接这样抹
Katrina: Just spread it directly like this.
Shure: 不是我直接那个
Shure: No, I mean just pour some more in.
Shure: 再往里倒点
Shure: Add a bit more.
Alice:感觉这火不太旺一般就是你那个油滴下去他不就会生个小火之类的
Alice: Feels like the fire isn't strong enough. Normally, when the oil drips, it should ignite a small flame or something.
Katrina: 煽风点火
Katrina: Fan the flames.
Katrina: 根本不用翻
Katrina: No need to flip it.
Katrina: 都没烤熟呢
Katrina: It's not cooked yet.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Katrina: 我说好像还不用翻
Katrina: I mean, we don't need to flip it yet.
Shure: 油呢
Shure: Where's the oil?
Katrina: 现在这个翻一下
Katrina: Flip it now.
Shure: 那咱就盐多放水
Shure: So, let's add more salt.
Shure: 水多放油
Shure: And more oil.
Katrina: 搞两片来不
Katrina: Should we add a few slices?
Katrina: 放点歌听
Katrina: Let's play some music.
Shure: 主要先尝一块
Shure: First, taste a piece.
Shure: 看看淡还是咸
Shure: See if it's bland or salty.
Shure: 直接浇上吧
Shure: Just pour it on.
Alice:1点点
Alice: Just a little.
Alice:筷子给我
Alice: Hand me the chopsticks.
Alice:在这上面撒一点点油
Alice: Drizzle a bit of oil on top.
Alice:再一点点就行
Alice: Just a little more.
Jake:谢谢你哇
Jake: Thank you.
Jake:就这样的
Jake: Just like that.
Alice:一点点就行
Alice: Just a little bit is enough.
Alice:我的天没事没事
Alice: Oh my god, it's fine, it's fine.
Alice:好抖腕非常不错
Alice: Good job with the shaking, very nice.
Shure: 跟没抖一样是吧
Shure: It's like you didn't shake at all, right?
Alice:我可没那么说
Alice: I didn't say that.
Katrina: 我办事我办事
Katrina: I'll handle it, I'll handle it.
Alice:没事
Alice: It's okay.
Alice:啥呀
Alice: What?
Shure: 这个这不好弄
Shure: This, this is hard to do.
Shure: 哎呦我操
Shure: Oh, damn.
Shure: 这烫不烫
Shure: Is this hot?
Alice:应该是烫的吧不太烫
Alice: It should be hot, but not too hot.
Alice:你摸摸
Alice: Feel it.
Shure: 卧槽凉的
Shure: Whoa, it's cold.
Shure: 多绿啊不够长是吗
Shure: How green is this, not long enough, huh?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Shure: 嗯操
Shure: Hmm, damn.
Alice:不然你以为
Alice: What did you expect?
Shure: 太他妈艰苦了
Shure: This is too damn tough.
Shure: 先放这吧
Shure: Let's just leave it here for now.
Katrina: 眼泪收回
Katrina: Hold back the tears.
Shure: 所以我们下次有哪些需要改进的
Shure: So, what do we need to improve next time?
Shure: 比如说碳
Shure: Like the charcoal.
Katrina: 就是要早点
Katrina: We need to start earlier.
Shure: 碳要再多一些是吗
Shure: Do we need more charcoal?
Alice:碳的短点
Alice: Shorten the charcoal.
Shure: 碳的多一点
Shure: More charcoal.
Shure: 就是买那种碎一点的碳是吧
Shure: You mean buy smaller pieces of charcoal, right?
Katrina: 碳
Katrina: Charcoal.
Alice:可以自己给它捣碎
Alice: You can crush it yourself.
Alice:碳是可以自己给它捣碎好的但我们今天没弄
Alice: The charcoal can be crushed, but we didn't do it today.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Alice:对
Alice:他没疯了
Alice: He didn't go crazy.
Alice:哎姐要疯的时候他不来
Alice: When I was about to lose it, he didn't come.
Alice:没事你们不用搁这闻烟了
Alice: It's okay, you guys don't have to smell the smoke here.
Alice:嫌呛的荒
Alice: The shoes are so annoying.
Shure: 这个最里面那个
Shure: The one inside.
Shure: 应该好吧
Shure: Should be good, right?
Katrina: 这好了吗赘肉
Katrina: Is this done, the fat?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 好了这是牛肉
Shure: It's done, this is beef.
Katrina: 牛排这是牛肉是吧
Katrina: This steak is beef, right?
Shure: 这是牛肉
Shure: Yes, it's beef.
Katrina: 反反正几分熟都能吃
Katrina: Anyway, it can be eaten at any doneness.
Alice:拿盘把
Katrina: 直接把哎
Katrina: Just put it directly.
Katrina: 为什么这个这么软呀
Katrina: Why is this one so soft?
Katrina: 还是说他本来就是这么软
Katrina: Or is it supposed to be this soft?
Katrina: 别的是硬的
Katrina: Others are harder.
Katrina: 他为什么是软的
Katrina: Why is this one soft?
Alice:放时间不太一样
Alice: The cooking time is different.
Alice:有个是刚上去
Alice: One piece just went on.
Katrina: 要不把它单独单独烤一下嘛
Katrina: How about we grill it separately?
Katrina: 要不要把这一块单独烤一下它好软
Katrina: Should we grill this piece separately? It's so soft.
Jake:我们看看
Jake: Let's take a look.
Alice:感觉也就这一块熟了
Alice: Seems like only this piece is done.
Alice:其他都不太行
Alice: The others aren't quite ready.
Shure: 来来
Shure: Come on.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Alice:跟进去吧
Alice: Let's go inside.
Alice:放时间不太一样
Alice: The cooking time is different.
Katrina: 甜品组跟烧烤哦
Katrina: Dessert and barbecue, oh.
Katrina: 洒水是什么意思啊
Katrina: What does sprinkling water mean?
Alice:嗯让它旺一点
Alice: Hmm, it makes it burn more.
Alice:然后不那么干吧
Alice: And not so dry, I guess.
Katrina: 啊洒水
Katrina: Ah, sprinkling water.
Katrina: 洒水跟山峰都可以
Katrina: Sprinkling water or adding oil, both work.
Katrina: 让他忘一点
Katrina: It makes it burn more.
Katrina: 然后加油也可以
Katrina: And adding oil is also fine.
Katrina: 是不是油是让他滴下去
Katrina: So the oil is meant to drip down?
Alice:对油是让它滴下去
Alice: Yes, the oil is meant to drip down.
Alice:然后就会有点小火
Alice: Then it will create a little flame.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Lucia: 蹑手蹑脚的靠近
Lucia: Sneak closer.
Katrina: 我感觉我真的是我用反面夹去
Katrina: I feel like I'm using the wrong side of the tongs.
Jake:好有两个好的
Jake: Okay, we have two good ones.
Shure: 跟平时的味完全不一样
Shure: The taste is completely different from usual.
Shure: 但是我又不知道差在哪
Shure: But I can't tell what's different.
Katrina: 哈哈哈这我觉得挺好吃
Katrina: Haha, I think it's quite tasty.
Katrina: 就不用自己调料
Katrina: No need for seasoning.
Shure: 大叔尝一块
Shure: Uncle, try a piece.
Alice:谢谢
Katrina: 拍点艺术照
Katrina: Let's take some artistic photos.
Katrina: 就这样远远看着你
Katrina: I'll just watch you from a distance.
Katrina: 是我最亲密的距离
Katrina: This is my closest distance with you.
Alice:是手机响了
Alice: The phone is ringing.
Katrina: 那你去拿
Katrina: Then go get it.
Alice:不是我的
Alice: It's not mine.
Alice:对
Katrina: 怎么他突然就那个了
Katrina: Why did he suddenly do that?
Alice:油滴下去了
Alice: The oil dripped down.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Katrina: 你平时做饭吗
Katrina: Do you usually cook?
Alice:做
Alice: Yes.
Katrina: 个人你比较熟练
Katrina: You seem pretty skilled.
Alice:还行
Alice: It's okay.
Alice:你要你得让他把这个火生起来
Alice: You have to get the fire going.
Alice:但是你又不能让他那个火真的烧到肉
Alice: But you can't let the fire actually touch the meat.
Alice:因为那个肉一烧他就糊了
Alice: Because if the meat burns, it gets charred.
Alice:就焦了对
Alice: It gets burnt, right.
Alice:所以不让他太高
Alice: So don't make it too high.
Alice:但是火大一点比较好吃
Alice: But a bigger flame makes it tastier.
Katrina: 这边翻一下
Katrina: Flip this side.
Alice:没事翻不翻都行
Alice: It's fine, you don't need to flip it.
Katrina: 这不用翻是吧
Katrina: No need to flip this, right?
Alice:你羊肉喜欢吃肥的还是瘦的
Alice: Do you like your lamb fatty or lean?
Katrina: 我们家我吃瘦肉
Katrina: At home, I eat lean meat.
Katrina: 我妈吃肥肉
Katrina: My mom eats fatty meat.
Alice:挺好
Alice: Nice.
Alice:我在家做饭就做我自己的
Alice: When I cook at home, I just cook for myself.
Katrina: 就那种普通的炒菜都行
Katrina: Just regular stir-fry dishes are fine.
Alice:额都是我喜欢做什么就做什么
Alice: Yeah, I just cook what I like.
Katrina: 你是哪人来着郑州
Katrina: Where are you from again? Zhengzhou?
Alice:郑州对
Alice: Zhengzhou, yes.
Katrina: 我舍友也是郑州
Katrina: My roommate is also from Zhengzhou.
Katrina: 郑州到武汉只要很近
Katrina: Zhengzhou is very close to Wuhan.
Katrina: 一个小时
Katrina: Just an hour away.
Alice:因为我们那个信阳
Alice: Because our place, Xinyang,
Alice:基本上就是挨着湖北的
Alice: is basically right next to Hubei.
Alice:中间几个差不多
Alice: So there are just a few in between.
Jake:哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake:那我得躺着坐
Jake: Then I have to sit lying down.
Alice:中间这几个还勉强
Alice: The ones in the middle are just okay.
Alice:行你要不拿一个先尝一下
Alice: Okay, why don't you take one and try it first?
Alice:这个可以
Alice: This one is good.
Alice:就变瘦的
Alice: It's slimming.
Alice:这个不错
Alice: This one's nice.
Alice:别让接下来再烤烤
Alice:这个再搁那吧
Alice: Let's put this one there.
Alice:鸡翅给他弄边嘛
Alice: Put the chicken wings on the side.
Alice:鸡翅巨难收
Alice: Chicken wings are hard to cook.
Alice:让他慢慢搞吧
Alice: Let it cook slowly.
Alice:嗯你看你想吃啥你放啥
Alice: Hmm, just put whatever you want to eat.
Alice:好了就不管那些生了熟的了
Alice: Alright, let's not worry about whether it's raw or cooked.
Alice:就这样吧
Alice: Just leave it like this.
Alice:还有别的有签的肉没了
Alice: Are there any more skewered meats left?
Alice:他们我们还我们现在跟不上吃的
Alice: They, we still can't keep up with the eating pace.
Katrina: 我们自己吃就行
Katrina: We can just eat by ourselves.
Alice:熟吗
Alice: Is it cooked?
Shure: 不是特别熟
Shure: Not very cooked.
Alice:搁上吧
Alice: Put it on.
Katrina: 没有带签的了
Katrina: There's no more skewered ones.
Alice:哎会掉
Alice: Oh, it might fall.
Alice:嗯没事
Alice: Hmm, it's okay.
Alice:一会用得搁到这上面
Alice: We'll need to put it on top later.
Alice:这片待会搁到这个上面烤把
Alice: This piece, let's grill it on top later.
Alice:这个熟没
Alice: Is this cooked?
Alice:不错
Alice:来赏你一块
Alice: Here, have a piece.
Shure: 来喽来喽
Shure: Coming, coming.
Alice:你尝尝
Alice: Try it.
Alice:他刚说不太熟
Alice: He just said it's not very cooked.
Katrina: 撒点水果
Katrina: Sprinkle some fruit.
Katrina: 我想尝试一下
Katrina: I want to try it.
Alice:你就这样
Alice: Just like this.
Alice:熟不熟
Alice: Is it cooked?
Shure: 应该差不多
Shure: Should be about done.
Alice:熟不熟
Alice: Is it cooked?
Shure: 熟了熟
Shure: It's cooked, it's cooked.
Shure: 了
Shure: Yes.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Alice:这是比较早搁进去
Alice: This one was put on earlier.
Shure: 这不能直接放
Shure: This can't be put directly.
Shure: 它会漏下去
Shure: It might leak.
Shure: darling just kiss me slow on my own
Shure: Darling, just kiss me slow on my own.
Alice:他们在里面玩啥
Alice: What are they playing inside?
Katrina: 他们在做蛋糕
Katrina: They're making cakes.
Katrina: 做了两三种好像
Katrina: They made two or three kinds, I think.
Katrina: 主要是杨靖康有点搞笑
Katrina: Mainly, Jake is being funny.
Shure: you between my arm
Shure: You between my arms.
Shure: barefoot on the grass
Shure: Barefoot on the grass.
Shure: 我就不不不喂你俩了
Shure: I'm not feeding you two anymore.
Shure: 每次都抱一双新筷子
Shure: Every time, I grab a new pair of chopsticks.
Shure: 然后发现哎
Shure: Then I realize, oh,
Shure: 我刚才有筷子
Shure: I already had chopsticks.
Shure: 来大叔随便吃点吧
Shure: Come on, uncle, just help yourself.
Alice:大叔谢谢
Alice: Thanks, uncle.
Shure: 自己家孩子怎么看都好看
Shure: Your own kids always look the best.
Alice:我觉得就差不多
Alice: I think that's about right.
Alice:这个差不多给
Alice: This one should be good.
Shure: 谢谢大厨
Shure: Thanks, chef.
Shure: 怎么样跳一段会吗
Shure: How about it, can you dance a bit?
Shure: 不是我说这个
Shure: Not that one, I meant this.
Katrina: 嗯不会
Katrina: Umm, no.
Katrina: 你会
Katrina: Can you?
Shure: 要学吗
Shure: Want to learn?
Katrina: 又会跳舞又会唱歌又会弹吉他牛啊
Katrina: You can dance, sing, and play guitar, impressive.
Katrina: 嗯好
Katrina: Umm, okay.
Shure: 这种三排的就适合
Shure: This three-row one is just right.
Shure: 我也忘了那叫什么舞了反正
Shure: I forgot what that dance is called, anyway.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice:给
Alice: Here.
Alice:应该差不多了
Alice: It should be about ready.
Alice:给你吃个
Alice: Here, have some.
Alice:有点烫啊
Alice: It's a bit hot.
Alice:熟了吧应该
Alice: It should be cooked, right?
Alice:抖了一
Alice: It's shaking.
Alice:不熟了再放回来就行了
Alice: If it's not cooked, just put it back.
Alice:我感觉不是很熟
Alice: I don't think it's fully cooked.
Shure: 哈哈哈别玩大的好吗哥们
Shure: Haha, don't play with the big ones, okay buddy?
Alice:差不多了
Alice: It's about done.